- Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу "Розуміння квантової
інформації та обчислень." Мене звати John Watrous, я є Технічним директором
IBM Quantum Education.
Це п'ятий урок серії, і він перший у
другому розділі серії, присвяченому квантовим алгоритмам.
У цьому розділі ми дослідимо
обчислювальні переваги квантової інформації, тобто розглянемо,
що ми можемо зробити
за допомогою квантових комп'ютерів і які переваги квантові комп'ютери потенційно можуть мати
над класичними комп'ютерами.
Ми зосередимося на тому, що можна зробити з одним квантовим комп'ютером, на відміну від розподіленого
середовища, наприклад,
де кілька квантових комп'ютерів взаємодіють через мережу певного роду.
Насправді, у розподілених середовищах також є квантові переваги, де в гру вступають зв'язок і
криптографія,
але ми не будемо
говорити про це в цьому розділі.
Цей розділ присвячений квантовим алгоритмам, що виконуються на окремих квантових комп'ютерах.
Почнімо з природного запитання. Які переваги може
потенційно запропонувати квантовий комп'ютер?
Головна перевага полягає в тому, що квантові комп'ютери можуть запропонувати швидші розв'язання деяких обчислювальних задач.
Час дорогоцінний, і хоча комп'ютери, якими ми
користуємося щодня, доволі швидкі, вони все одно надто повільні,
щоб розв'язати певні обчислювальні задачі — просто через притаманну
обчислювальну складність цих задач.
Ця потенційна можливість квантових комп'ютерів дозволяти нам розв'язувати задачі, які класичні комп'ютери
розв'язують надто повільно,
— саме це рухало
дослідженнями квантових алгоритмів протягом останніх кількох десятиліть.
Є й інші обчислювальні
ресурси, крім часу, які можна розглядати, наприклад, обсяг пам'яті комп'ютера, необхідний для обчислень,
але квантові комп'ютери не можуть
запропонувати надто багато заощаджень з точки зору пам'яті, як виявляється, а класична пам'ять комп'ютера досить недорога
особливо порівняно з квантовою пам'яттю. Тому тут просто немає
великих перспектив.
Ми також могли б думати про інші ресурси, наприклад, про кількість енергії,
необхідної для обчислень, але для класичних обчислень тобі насправді
не потрібно багато енергії
особливо якщо ти готовий
уповільнити процес.
Тому саме час,
необхідний для обчислень, є нашим головним фокусом.
Ось огляд уроку, який присвячений конкретній
моделі обчислень, відомій як модель запитів.
Можна думати про цю модель як про щось схоже на чашку Петрі для розвитку алгоритмічних ідей — як квантових, так і класичних.
Вона не призначена бути практичною моделлю, яка описує типи
обчислювальних задач, що ми зустрічаємо в реальному житті.
У наступних уроках цього розділу ми відійдемо від моделі запитів і зосередимося натомість на моделях, вмотивованих більш практичними
поняттями обчислень,
але модель запитів є
дуже хорошою відправною точкою.
Це проста модель, яка дозволяє нам досліджувати
потенціал квантових комп'ютерів без зайвих технічних
деталей,
а також дозволяє ізолювати деякі
справді важливі ідеї квантових обчислень і того, як вони працюють.
Квантові обчислення, власне, спершу розвивалися саме в цій моделі, і ідеї, розроблені в ній, безпосередньо надихнули
важливі квантові алгоритми
такі як алгоритм Шора для факторизації.
У першому розділі уроку ми розглянемо, що конкретно являє собою модель запитів обчислень,
а в другому, третьому
і четвертому розділах ми обговоримо три
квантових алгоритми запитів, а саме алгоритм Дойча,
алгоритм Дойча-Йожі
та алгоритм Саймона, які розкривають дедалі більш
вражаючі переваги
квантових комп'ютерів
над класичними комп'ютерами в рамках моделі запитів обчислень.
Щоб пояснити модель запитів обчислень, почнімо спочатку з більш стандартної
абстракції обчислень.
Ось зображення, яке
представляє обчислення в дуже простих та базових термінах.
Маємо вхідні дані, які зазвичай мають
форму двійкового рядка, хоча ми могли б використовувати інші
символи за бажанням.
Вхідні дані надаються обчисленню, яке представлене синім
прямокутником на цьому зображенні,
і результатом обчислення є деякий вивід, і знову ж таки, це найчастіше
двійковий рядок.
Звичайно, це зображення
зовсім не уточнює, як саме відбувається обчислення.
Ми можемо формулювати різні
конкретні обчислювальні моделі для цього, наприклад, машини Тьюринга
та булеві circuit,
або квантові circuit, якщо ми думаємо про
квантові обчислення.
Це зображення
не відображає той факт, що багато
комп'ютерів, якими ми користуємося щодня, постійно отримують
вхідні дані та видають вихідні,
по суті взаємодіючи з нами та з іншими комп'ютерами через
інтернет, наприклад.
Але ми не намагаємося тут
представити ці взаємодії.
Це про моделювання
ізольованих обчислювальних завдань.
Наприклад, вхідними даними може бути
двійкове кодування числа або представлення матриці
WEBVTT
або опис молекули або справді будь-що інше, що ми маємо на увазі, і є деяке обчислювальне завдання,
що виконується лише над цими вхідними даними.
Ключова думка тут полягає в тому, що
всі вхідні дані надаються обчисленню, і нічого зі
вхідних даних від нього не приховано.
Модель запитів
обчислень працює інакше.
У моделі запитів вхідні дані стають доступними
у формі функції, до якої обчислення може
звертатися, роблячи запити,
або, іншими словами, обчислюючи функцію
на різних вхідних даних.
Тут ти бачиш це представлення
у формі зображення.
Схоже до того, що ми мали раніше, обчислення представлено
синім прямокутником, але замість отримання вхідних даних безпосередньо
у формі рядка
бітів, наприклад, воно отримує вхідні дані, фактично ставлячи запитання
та отримуючи відповіді.
Ми іноді використовуємо
терміни "оракул" і "чорна скринька" для позначення механізму,
що надає вхідні дані.
Між оракулом та чорною скринькою є різниця
в теорії складності, але це зовсім не має значення для цілей цього обговорення.
Так чи інакше, ці терміни
призначені передати основну ідею.
У Стародавній Греції ти
міг прийти до оракула, наприклад до Дельфійського оракула,
і поставити важливе запитання,
і оракул відповідав
на це конкретне запитання, але вона точно не розповіла б тобі все, що знала.
У схожому дусі, коли ми
думаємо про чорну скриньку, ми уявляємо якийсь
процес або систему,
де ми можемо обрати, що туди потрапляє, і бачимо, що виходить, але не маємо жодного розуміння
її внутрішнього механізму.
І це саме наш випадок. Вхідні дані задачі
мають форму функції, і все, що ми можемо робити, —
це обчислювати цю функцію,
але в іншому відношенні ми не маємо
жодних знань чи розуміння того, як вона працює.
Протягом уроку
ми будемо зберігати літеру f для функції, що
представляє вхідні дані, і зробимо припущення,
що вона завжди має
форму, яку ти бачиш прямо тут.
Сигма позначає двійковий алфавіт, тому f — це функція від рядків
бітів до рядків бітів,
і зокрема, ми
припускаємо, що вхідні дані для f — це рядок бітів довжиною n, а вихідні — рядок
бітів довжиною m,
де n і m — додатні цілі числа.
Для різних задач ми
матимемо обмеження на n і m, але в усіх випадках вхідна функція матиме
таку форму.
Коли ми говоримо, що
обчислення робить запит, ми маємо на увазі, що функція f обчислюється один раз,
тобто обчислення вибирає деякий рядок x довжиною N, і рядок f від x
стає йому доступним
від оракула або чорної скриньки. І нарешті, дуже простий спосіб вимірювання обчислювальної вартості
алгоритму запитів — це підрахунок кількості запитів, які він потребує.
Отже, хоча насправді
нас найбільше цікавить тривалість обчислень, коли ми вивчаємо модель запитів,
ми зазвичай спрощуємо
і просто рахуємо запити, і саме це ми робитимемо в цьому уроці.
Тепер розглянемо кілька
прикладів задач на запити, тобто обчислювальних
задач у моделі запитів,
і тут, до речі, я просто
опишу самі задачі, і наразі нічого не скажу
про те, як їх розв'язувати.
Перша задача — це задача АБО.
У цьому випадку вхідні дані — це функція
від n бітів до 1 біту, тобто m дорівнює 1 для цієї задачі,
і необхідний вихід
задачі — це або 1, або 0.
Якщо існує деякий рядок x з n бітів, для якого f від x дорівнює 1, то правильна відповідь — 1,
а інакше, якщо f від x завжди дорівнює 0 для кожного рядка x, то правильна відповідь — 0.
Отже, якщо ми думаємо про функцію f як про надання нам довільного
доступу до двох у степені n бітів, по одному для кожного рядка x з n бітів,
то задача полягає
в знаходженні АБО цих бітів, і саме тому вона називається задачею АБО.
Ще один приклад — задача парності, схожа на задачу АБО, але вона вимагає визначення парності,
або, іншими словами, виключного АБО всіх однобітових
вихідних значень функції.
Інший спосіб сказати це —
правильна відповідь 0, якщо кількість рядків x з n бітів, для яких f від x дорівнює 1, парна,
і правильна відповідь
1, якщо це число непарне.
Приклад задачі, де m не обов'язково дорівнює 1, — це задача мінімуму.
Тут функція f має звичайну форму, і немає обмежень на n і m,
і правильна відповідь — це яке б вихідне значення
функції стоїть першим у лексикографічному
або словниковому порядку
двійкових рядків. Альтернативно, якщо ти хочеш
думати про рядки довжиною m як про представлення невід'ємних
цілих чисел у двійковому записі,
то правильна відповідь —
це найменше можливе або мінімальне значення, яке
видає ця функція.
WEBVTT
Іноді ми також розглядаємо задачі на запити, де є обіцянка
щодо вхідної функції, або, іншими словами, деяка
гарантія щодо неї,
і ми не переймаємося функціями, що не відповідають цій обіцянці.
Функції, що не задовольняють обіцянку, вважаються вхідними даними типу "нас не цікавить".
І ми просто не несемо відповідальності за те, що відбувається на таких вхідних даних.
Ось приклад задачі на запити з обіцянкою, яка називається "унікальний пошук".
Вона пов'язана із задачею АБО,
але відрізняється від неї.
Вхідна функція має ту саму
форму, що й для задачі АБО, тобто вона відображає
рядки з n бітів у біти.
Цього разу нам обіцяно, що
існує рівно один рядок Z, який змушує f обчислитися в 1,
тоді як f від x дорівнює 0
для кожного рядка x, крім z, і правильний вивід —
це цей унікальний рядок z.
Звичайно, є
варіанти функції f, що не задовольняють цій умові, але ми взагалі не ставимо жодних вимог
до алгоритмів для цієї задачі, коли їм подаються такі
функції як вхідні дані.
Нас цікавлять лише функції, що задовольняють обіцянку.
Тепер, усі чотири
задачі, що я щойно згадав, є цілком природними, тобто їх легко пояснити,
і легко уявити ситуації, в яких може виникнути потреба їх розв'язати, але деякі задачі на запити
зовсім не такі.
Насправді, іноді ми розглядаємо надзвичайно
штучні задачі на запити, де важко уявити, що хтось коли-небудь
справді захотів би їх розв'язати.
Задача Саймона, яку ми
побачимо пізніше в уроці, певною мірою підпадає під цю категорію, але є й інші
що набагато гірші в певному сенсі, але вони, тим не менш, насправді виявляються досить важливими для вивчення моделі запитів.
Ми вивчаємо ці задачі не обов'язково тому, що хочемо
розв'язувати їх на практиці.
Можна думати про це так: ми шукаємо
крайнощі різних видів,
зокрема, коли ми працюємо
в рамках цієї моделі-чашки Петрі, природний спосіб дослідження
квантових алгоритмічних ідей —
формулювати надзвичайно штучні задачі, де ми можемо найкраще використати
потужність квантових комп'ютерів.
І це може насправді
пролити багато світла на те, як квантові комп'ютери
можуть бути корисними в більш практичних контекстах.
Ми можемо формалізувати поняття
запиту по-різному, залежно від того, з якою обчислювальною
моделлю ми працюємо.
Наприклад, у моделі обчислень
на машині Тьюринга, про яку ми не говорили і в цій серії не будемо,
є певний спосіб
формалізації поняття запиту, що має сенс для цієї моделі.
Для моделей circuit ми визначаємо спеціальні типи
gate, які називаються gate запитів, і саме так запити
формально представляються.
Для булевих circuit є дуже простий спосіб зробити це — просто уявити,
що ми маємо gate запитів,
які безпосередньо обчислюють вхідну функцію, як ти бачиш тут на екрані.
Ідея полягає в тому, що ми можемо
використовувати ці gate запитів для побудови circuit, які розв'язують будь-яку
задачу, що нас цікавить,
і щоб працювати правильно, circuit мають давати правильну відповідь для будь-якої вхідної функції f,
за умови, що вона відповідає обіцянці у випадку задачі з обіцянкою.
Ось простий приклад
булевого circuit, що розв'язує задачу парності, коли n дорівнює 1,
тобто вхідна функція f відображає
1 біт в 1 біт у цьому випадку.
Цей circuit обчислює функцію
f на вхідних даних 0 і 1 за допомогою цих двох gate запитів.
Потім він підставляє два вихідних значення, отримані від gate запитів, у булевий circuit з уроку три, що обчислює XOR,
що є тим самим, що й парність.
Щоб бути зрозумілим, ці два
вхідні значення тут не є вхідними даними задачі,
тобто задачі парності,
коли ми працюємо з моделлю запитів, вхідні дані задачі —
це функція f, і ти маєш думати про ці
два вхідних значення circuit
як про жорстко закодовані
значення, що ніколи не змінюються, по суті вони є частиною алгоритму.
Ми хочемо обчислити XOR від f 0 і f 1, тому ми ініціалізували ці
два дроти саме таким чином,
щоб це працювало. Ми використали два gate запитів
тут, цей і цей,
і тому алгоритм, представлений
цим булевим circuit, робить два запити, і якщо ми розглянемо задачу парності на мить
для функцій від одного біта до одного біта, ми бачимо, що це абсолютно необхідно для будь-якого булевого circuit,
що розв'язує цю задачу,
робити щонайменше два запити.
Якщо зробити лише один запит, тобто знати лише одне
вихідне значення функції f, але не інше, то насправді немає
жодної інформації
про парність, оскільки інше вихідне значення
може з однаковою ймовірністю бути 0 або 1, що призведе до будь-якого з двох можливих розв'язань
задачі. Отже, з точки зору кількості
запитів, що він робить, цей булевий circuit є оптимальним
для задачі парності
при n, що дорівнює 1.
WEBVTT
Є ще один момент щодо gate запитів, про який варто згадати, перш ніж ми рухатимемося далі: коли ми проектуємо та аналізуємо алгоритми запитів,
ми взагалі не переймаємося тим, як
реалізовані gate запитів.
Передбачається, що ці
gate запитів нам надані, і складність їх побудови
нас не стосується.
Ти можеш думати про самі
gate запитів як про вхідні дані, якщо хочеш, і не наше завдання створювати вхідні дані — ми просто намагаємося
розв'язати конкретну задачу
за наявності вхідних даних. Звичайно, коли f — функція
від одного біта до одного біта, є лише чотири можливих варіанти,
і реалізувати будь-який з них
було б достатньо просто, але загалом для функцій
з багатьма вхідними бітами,
реалізувати gate запитів
для таких функцій може бути надзвичайно складно.
Щоб бути зрозумілим, це не
означає, що питання реалізації gate запитів
не є важливим, а скоріше, що воно не розглядається
як частина вартості
алгоритму запитів.
Це узгоджується з ідеєю, що це не про практичні обчислення або фактичну побудову circuit як таких,
а про роботу в рамках
теоретичної основи, яка розповідає нам цікаві
речі про обчислення.
Ми матимемо більше що сказати про це, коли зробимо перехід від цієї моделі до більш стандартної моделі обчислень, і це головним чином те, про що наступний урок,
Урок 6, буде.
Тепер звернімо увагу
на квантові circuit.
Для квантових circuit ми збираємося змінити
визначення gate запитів, щоб зробити їх унітарними.
Ми хочемо мати можливість робити
запити в квантових circuit і щоб вони діяли
лінійно на квантові стани,
щоб ми могли ефективно
робити запити в суперпозиції.
Може здатися, що ми
переставляємо ворота, так би мовити, змінюючи те, що ми маємо на увазі під запитом, порівняно з тим, що ми щойно
бачили для булевих circuit,
але є виправдання для цього, яке ми обговоримо докладніше в наступному уроці.
Наразі це просто визначення.
Зокрема, визначення
таке: для будь-якої функції f тієї ж форми, що й раніше,
тобто яка відображає рядки з n бітів
у рядки з m бітів, gate запиту Uf діє на n + m qubit
і визначається
дією, описаною тут, на стандартні базисні стани.
Ми побачимо зображення,
що представляє це визначення, за мить, але спочатку дозвольте мені прояснити нотацію,
яку тут використано,
а саме: коли ми
використовуємо символ XOR як операцію між двома
рядками однакової довжини,
ми маємо на увазі
побітове виключне АБО, і тут ти можеш побачити приклад.
У визначенні обидва y і f від
x — це рядки довжиною m, тому цей рядок тут
представляє рядок, який ми отримуємо
XOR-ячи ці два рядки
разом, біт за бітом, і ось діаграма,
що пояснює, як ці gate працюють.
Верхні n qubit відповідають
аргументу функції.
І коли вони починаються
зі стандартного базисного стану, кет x на цій діаграмі, цей стандартний базисний стан
проходить незміненим
і відображається як частина виводу.
Нижні m qubit відповідають виводу
функції f, і коли вони починаються в
будь-якому стандартному базисному стані,
кет y на цій діаграмі, відбувається наступне: вивід функції f від x XOR-ується на рядок y.
Це те, що відбувається для
стандартних базисних станів, і якщо ми хочемо знати,
що відбувається в загальному випадку для інших квантових станів, ми
використовуємо лінійність, як завжди.
Причина визначення gate запитів таким чином, де ми відображаємо вхідні дані та використовуємо побітове XOR для виводу,
полягає в тому, що ці gate завжди унітарні для будь-якого вибору функції f.
Це, власне, є
детерміністична операція.
І якщо ми виразимо її як матрицю для будь-якого вибору функції F, ми отримаємо матрицю перестановок,
тобто таку, де в кожному рядку та в кожному стовпці стоїть одна одиниця, а всі інші елементи дорівнюють 0.
А матриці перестановок
завжди унітарні.
Власне, для цієї операції ми отримаємо, що операція
є своєю власною оберненою, тому Uf кинджал дорівнює Uf.
Якщо все, що ми хочемо робити з цими
gate, — обчислювати f від x для деякого рядка x, це просто,
ми можемо просто встановити y як
рядок із самих нулів. Тоді, коли ми беремо XOR бітів y, отримуємо просто f від x.
До речі, тут ти бачиш нотацію, що використовується для позначення рядка із самих нулів.
Він виглядає як 0 у степені M, але це не те, що він означає.
Він означає рядок із нулів
довжиною, що дорівнює M.
Коли ми говоримо про
рядки, а не числа, степені зазвичай означають, що ми повторюємо цей рядок
певну кількість разів,
тому це 0, повторений m разів.
WEBVTT
Це просто зручний і точний спосіб описати цей рядок.
Ще раз, коли ми
працюємо з моделлю запитів, ми не переймаємося тим, як
реалізувати ці gate запитів.
Це та сама проблема,
яку ми мали з gate запитів для булевого circuit.
Не наше завдання підготовляти вхідні дані — нам дають вхідні дані у
формі цих gate запитів.
Зауважу, однак, що якщо ми знаємо, як
реалізувати функцію f за допомогою булевого circuit, то можливо
перекласти цю реалізацію
доволі безпосередньо у реалізацію квантового circuit
для Uf, і ми побачимо точно, як
це працює, в наступному уроці.
Як відступ, досить просто створити булевий circuit,
який діє таким чином, використовуючи один класичний
gate запиту для функції f,
але це суттєво відрізняється від наявності реалізації квантового
circuit для цього унітарного gate.
Проте суть у тому, що
для класичних алгоритмів запитів наявність gate запиту, що працює таким чином, фактично еквівалентна
наявності звичайного
класичного gate запиту для f, в тому сенсі, що кожен із них може бути реалізований за допомогою іншого.
У цьому розділі уроку ми розглянемо алгоритм Дойча, який є дуже простим
квантовим алгоритмом запитів, але він справді є справжнім скарбом.
Цей алгоритм походить зі статті 1985 року, написаної David Deutsch, який був одним із перших людей, що працював над теоретичними
основами квантових обчислень.
Сам алгоритм представляє дуже невелику частину
статті Deutsch 1985 року, і, власне,
алгоритм, який ми зараз
називаємо алгоритмом Дойча, насправді є вдосконаленою версією алгоритму, описаного Deutsch.
Він надає дуже скромний приклад того, як квантові комп'ютери можуть
пропонувати обчислювальні переваги, але треба з чогось починати,
і це справді була важлива іскра, що все запустила.
Алгоритм Дойча розв'язує задачу на запити, яку часто називають задачею Дойча в контексті квантових обчислень,
але насправді це не що інше,
як задача парності для функцій від одного біта до одного біта, про яку ми вже говорили.
Як ми вже бачили, є чотири функції
від одного біта до одного біта, і вони описані тут на екрані таблицями значень.
Перша і остання з цих
функцій є константними, тоді як дві середні є збалансованими в тому сенсі, що два
можливих вихідних значення
зустрічаються однакову кількість разів.
Для двох константних функцій
ми бачимо, що парність, або, іншими словами, виключне АБО двох виходів дорівнює 0,
а для двох збалансованих функцій парність виходів дорівнює 1.
Отже, еквівалентний спосіб
описати задачу парності в цьому конкретному випадку, де функція f приймає
один біт як вхід,
або, іншими словами, задачу Дойча, такий, як ти бачиш тут.
Вхідні дані — це функція f
від одного біта до одного біта, і вивід — 0, якщо f константна,
і 1, якщо f збалансована.
Як я вже зазначив, кожен класичний алгоритм запитів,
що розв'язує цю задачу, повинен робити щонайменше два запити до f.
Якщо ти дізнаєшся лише одне з
двох вихідних значень f, у тебе все одно взагалі немає інформації про парність двох виходів.
І це, до речі, справедливо
навіть для класичних алгоритмів, що використовують випадковість.
Випадковість іноді може бути дуже корисною для розв'язання задач на запити, і ми побачимо приклад
трохи пізніше в уроці,
але тут випадковість не допомагає.
Тому наш попередній алгоритм є оптимальним серед класичних алгоритмів запитів
для задачі Дойча.
Тепер ми розглянемо
алгоритм Дойча, який є квантовим алгоритмом запитів, що розв'язує задачу Дойча
за один запит.
І ось алгоритм,
описаний як квантовий circuit.
Маємо два qubit,
ініціалізованих, як ти бачиш тут: верхній ініціалізований у кет 0, а нижній — у кет 1,
і ми незабаром побачимо, чому ми ініціалізуємо ці qubit саме так.
Ми виконуємо gate Hadamard
на двох qubit, подаємо їх у gate запиту, виконуємо ще один gate Hadamard
на верхньому qubit,
а потім вимірюємо його. І стверджується, що
результат вимірювання дає нам, з упевненістю,
правильну відповідь на задачу.
Отже, проаналізуємо
circuit крок за кроком, щоб побачити точно, як він працює.
Стан двох qubit після першого шару gate Hadamard — це тензорний добуток
станів мінус і плюс.
Hadamard зверху відображає
стан 0 у стан плюс, а Hadamard знизу відображає стан 1 у стан мінус.
Верхній qubit знаходиться праворуч, а нижній — ліворуч, тому це стан, який ми отримуємо.
Дуже важливо, що нижній qubit знаходиться у стані мінус, до речі, це не спрацювало б, якщо ми
ініціалізуємо нижній qubit
у стан 0 замість стану 1.
Ми збираємося розгорнути цей стан
наполовину, як ти бачиш тут.
Причина для цього
наразі незрозуміла, але це буде зручно
за мить.
Далі поміркуємо про
стан двох qubit після виконання gate запиту.
Gate запиту
працює так: він обчислює F на стандартному базисному
стані верхнього qubit і XOR-ує значення
на нижній qubit,
WEBVTT
і тут ми бачимо
результат цього.
Для першого доданка стандартний базисний стан
верхнього qubit дорівнює 0, тому f від нуля XOR-ується
на нижній qubit,
і це діє за лінійністю. Аналогічно для другого доданка, крім того, що стандартний базисний стан
для верхнього qubit дорівнює 1, тому ми XOR-уємо f від 1 на нижній qubit.
І на цьому етапі ми можемо
спростити цей вираз, спостерігаючи формулу,
яку ти бачиш внизу, яка працює, коли a дорівнює або 0, або 1.
І ми можемо просто перевірити це для цих двох значень окремо.
Якщо a дорівнює 0, то
XOR з a нічого не робить, і від'ємна 1 у степені 0 дорівнює 1,
тому обидві сторони рівні. А якщо a дорівнює 1, ми отримуємо кет 1 мінус кет
0 при XOR,
що є від'ємною 1
помноженою на кет 0 мінус кет 1.
І якщо ми використовуємо цю формулу
для спрощення нашого стану, де беремо a, що дорівнює f від 0, ліворуч і a, що дорівнює f від 1, праворуч,
ми отримуємо вираз,
який ти бачиш прямо тут.
Отже, порівнюючи два
вектори квантового стану π1 і π2, ми бачимо, що gate Uf ефективно
поміщає
одне з двох значень, f від 0 або f від 1, у
степінь від'ємної 1,
або, іншими словами, у
фазу кожного доданка.
Це причина
ініціалізації нижнього qubit у 1 та виконання gate Hadamard на ньому для створення стану мінус,
що дозволяє цьому відбуватися.
Це називається феноменом фазового відбою, і ми повернемося до нього за кілька хвилин, щоб розглянути його ще раз.
Це досить важливо, і ми побачимо його ще
кілька разів у цьому уроці, а також у наступних уроках.
Тепер ми можемо спростити, винісши
стан мінус назад зовні, щоб отримати вираз,
який ти бачиш прямо тут.
Як відступ, це
доволі цікаво помітити, що тут насправді
немає жодного заплутування.
Обидва ці стани є добутними станами. Отже, хоча заплутування
надзвичайно цікаве,
воно не відіграє
жодної ролі в цьому конкретному алгоритмі.
Давайте трохи приберемо, щоб мати трохи більше місця.
Що ми тепер можемо зробити —
винести множник від'ємної 1 у степені f від нуля зовні
щоб отримати вираз для
стану, який ти бачиш прямо тут.
Ти помітиш, що прямо тут у степені від'ємної 1 знаходиться виключне АБО від f 0 і f 1.
Можна було б очікувати, що це
буде f від 1 мінус f від 0, тому що ми виносимо множник від'ємної 1 у степені f від 0,
але ми отримуємо те саме
значення, якщо беремо XOR, тому що це біти, і єдине, що має значення, коли маємо ціле число у
степені від'ємної 1,
— чи є це ціле число парним чи непарним.
Ще один спосіб виразити цей
стан — такий, як тут, де ми просто розглядаємо
два можливих випадки для XOR.
і це зручний
спосіб виразити стан, коли ми розглядаємо дію
фінального gate Hadamard разом із вимірюванням.
Коли ми виконуємо останній
gate Hadamard на верхньому qubit, стан плюс
перетворюється на стан 0
а стан мінус
перетворюється на стан 1, що ми можемо записати більш
стисло ось так.
І нарешті, коли
виконується вимірювання, отриманий результат — це
XOR від f 0 і f 1,
що є значенням, яке ми шукаємо, і саме так працює алгоритм Дойча.
Це доволі просто, і якщо ми запитаємо себе, що
змушує це працювати, дозволяючи нам обчислити
парність двох бітів
за один запит замість двох, розумна відповідь —
це інтерференція.
Ми фактично
обчислюємо f від 0 і f від 1 одночасно, тому що спочатку виконали
gate Hadamard
на верхньому qubit, щоб помістити вхід у f у
суперпозицію 0 і 1.
І завдяки фазовому відбою разом із фінальним gate Hadamard ми фактично створюємо
конструктивну інтерференцію
для правильної відповіді та деструктивну інтерференцію
для неправильної відповіді.
Тому ми не бачимо неправильної відповіді, ми бачимо лише правильну відповідь.
Дозвольте тепер більше сказати про феномен фазового відбою, щоб розглянути його під
дещо іншим кутом.
По-перше, зауважимо
цю дуже просту формулу, де b і c є довільними двійковими значеннями.
Коротко кажучи, XOR біта b зі значенням 1 — це те саме, що виконати gate NOT або операцію x над b,
і звичайно, XOR
біта b зі значенням 0 нічого з ним не робить, що є тим самим, що виконати
операцію тотожності над ним.
І ми можемо виразити операцію тотожності як x у степені 0.
Отже, якщо ми виконуємо gate Uf на двох qubit у стандартному базисному
стані кет b тензор кет a,
ми отримуємо цей результат, просто за визначенням gate Uf.
WEBVTT
і використовуючи формулу, ми можемо альтернативно записати цей стан, як ти бачиш прямо тут.
Ця формула працює для всіх значень b, тому за лінійністю вона працює
для довільного стану СІ
замість кет b.
І зокрема, якщо ми хочемо, можемо вибрати СІ як стан мінус.
І тут ключ до того, чому відбувається феномен фазового відбою x.
Це тому, що операція x,
застосована до стану мінус, дає нам від'ємну 1 помножену на стан мінус.
Математично ми говоримо, що стан мінус є
власним вектором операції x з власним значенням, що дорівнює від'ємній 1.
Власні вектори та власні значення
надзвичайно важливі в лінійній алгебрі, а також
у квантовій інформації, і ми будемо мати багато
що сказати про них
у міру продовження серії.
Але наразі нам потрібна
лише ця проста формула.
І використовуючи її, ми можемо
спростити наш вектор стану.
І саме це є по суті феноменом фазового відбою, записаним у вигляді формули.
Це працює тому, що стан мінус
є власним вектором операції NOT з
власним значенням від'ємна одиниця.
Ми узагальнимо це
дуже суттєво в Уроці 7, коли звернемося до процедури оцінки фази, яка є тим, що рухає
алгоритм факторизації Шора.
Ми можемо бачити цю формулу в дії при аналізі алгоритму Дойча
наступним чином.
Перед gate запиту наш стан — це тензорний добуток станів мінус і плюс.
Потім ми застосовуємо gate запиту, і розкриття стану плюс
дає нам цей стан.
Тепер ми застосовуємо формулу фазового відбою, щоб отримати цей вираз, і далі аналіз
продовжується, як і раніше.
Це те саме, що й раніше, але тут ми просто
зосереджуємося на фазовому відбої, щоб ми могли його розпізнати
і бути готовими до нього,
коли він знову з'явиться.
Далі ми звернемося до
алгоритму Дойча-Йожі, який є розширенням
алгоритму Дойча, що насправді розв'язує кілька
різних задач на запити.
Перевага, яку
алгоритм Дойча надає над класичними алгоритмами,
досить скромна — один запит проти двох.
Алгоритм Дойча-Йожі збільшує цю перевагу дещо, і я поясню, що я маю на увазі
під цим, коли ми дійдемо до нього.
Алгоритм Дойча-Йожі можна розглядати як природний і прямий спосіб розширення алгоритму Дойча
від функцій від одного біта до одного біта до функцій від n бітів до одного біта, або іншими словами, функцій такої форми.
Як квантовий circuit алгоритм Дойча-Йожі
виглядає ось так, і я буду посилатися на це
як на circuit Дойча-Йожі
лише для того, щоб провести незначне
розрізнення між цим circuit і самим алгоритмом Дойча-Йожі, тому що є ще
класичний крок постобробки.
Ідея полягає в тому, що якщо ми запустимо
цей circuit і виміряємо, ми отримаємо деякий рядок y з n бітів,
що розповість нам щось
про функцію f.
На цьому етапі, до речі, я насправді ще не сказав,
яка задача на запити, яку ми сподіваємося
розв'язати за допомогою цього circuit — це скоро буде.
Але суть у тому, що
запустивши цей circuit, ми отримаємо деяку інформацію про f, яка потенційно може допомогти
нам розв'язувати задачі на запити
де f є вхідними даними. І як я сказав мить тому, ми насправді можемо використовувати цей circuit
для розв'язання кількох
різних задач на запити.
По-перше, розглянемо
задачу на запити, відому як задача Дойча-Йожі, яка є задачею, для розв'язання якої circuit Дойча-Йожі
був спочатку задуманий.
Задача Дойча-Йожі — це узагальнення задачі Дойча, де мета — визначити, чи є дана функція
константною або збалансованою.
Зауваж, що це не природний спосіб узагальнити задачу парності
до функцій такої форми.
Тут ми не обчислюємо парність, завдання — вивести 0, якщо
функція f константна,
і 1, якщо функція f збалансована.
Перше, що варто помітити про
цю задачу: коли n, кількість вхідних бітів
для функції f, не менше 2,
існують варіанти функції, що є ні константними, ні збалансованими.
Наприклад, ось
функція від 2 бітів до 1 біта, що є ні константною, ні збалансованою.
Вона не константна, тому що обидва двійкові значення
зустрічаються серед виходів, і вона не збалансована,
тому що два вихідних значення
зустрічаються з різною частотою. 0 зустрічається три рази
і 1 — лише один раз.
Щоб бути збалансованою,
виходи 0 і 1 повинні зустрічатися рівно
однакову кількість разів.
Той факт, що є функції, що є ні константними, ні збалансованими, коли n не менше 2, — це нормально, ми просто розглянемо
такі функції
як вхідні дані типу "нас не цікавить". Тобто, це
задача з обіцянкою.
І ось точне
формулювання задачі.
WEBVTT
Нам обіцяно, що вхідна функція f є або константною, або збалансованою, і мета — з'ясувати,
яка саме.
І ми не несемо відповідальності за те, що відбувається, якщо вхідні дані
не відповідають обіцянці.
Алгоритм Дойча-Йожі,
що розв'язує цю задачу, — це спочатку запустити circuit Дойча-Йожі, а потім вивести 0,
якщо рядок, який ми
отримуємо від вимірювань, — це рядок із самих нулів,
і вивести 1 інакше.
Інший спосіб сказати це — ми виводимо АБО
бітів, які вимірюємо.
Щоб проаналізувати алгоритм Дойча-Йожі, буде корисно
спочатку витратити кілька хвилин на роздуми про gate Hadamard.
Ми можемо, звичайно, описати операцію Hadamard
як матрицю, але також можемо описати
її через її дію
на стандартні базисні стани,
як ти бачиш прямо тут.
Ці два рівняння можна
об'єднати в одне рівняння, яке описує, як
операція Hadamard працює для a, що є одним із
двох двійкових значень,
і ми можемо трохи піти далі та виразити те, що
отримуємо, як суму ось так.
Використовуючи цю формулу, ми можемо вивести формулу, що описує, як шар
gate Hadamard працює, де ми застосовуємо один gate Hadamard
до кожного з n qubit.
Тут ми описуємо цю
дію на стандартних базисних станах.
І щоб зрозуміти нотацію: коли ми пишемо h тензор n ось так, де тензор n — це верхній індекс,
ми маємо на увазі n-кратний
тензорний добуток H із самим собою, або, іншими словами, n копій
h, об'єднаних тензорним добутком.
Ми застосовуємо цю операцію
до стандартного базисного стану, і тут я дотримуюся
конвенції, яку використовує Qiskit,
для індексування двійкових рядків, просто тому що це гарний час
для представлення цієї конвенції.
Отже, x0 — це біт, x1 — це біт,
і так далі, всього n бітів, і біти впорядковані,
як ти бачиш тут на екрані.
Можна думати про цей
спосіб індексування бітів як про відповідність їх значущості, якщо ми розглядаємо рядки як
представлення цілих чисел
у двійковому записі, наприклад.
Якщо ми застосовуємо gate Hadamard
до кожного з цих qubit, ми можемо альтернативно виразити результат як n-кратний тензорний добуток
gate Hadamard, застосованого до кожного qubit, а потім ми можемо застосовувати нашу формулу до кожного тензорного множника.
І тут ми використовуємо
назви y і від'ємна 1 до y1 замість b у формулі,
тому це двійкові значення. І ми переконуємося використовувати нову назву кожного разу, коли застосовуємо формулу.
Якщо потім розгорнути все за допомогою мультилінійності
тензорних добутків, ми отримаємо вираз,
який ти бачиш прямо тут.
І щоб бути зрозумілим, n сум
об'єднуються в одну суму, але ми все ще підсумовуємо
над усіма можливими значеннями
для окремих двійкових значень.
Тепер наведемо порядок, щоб ми могли просунутися трохи далі.
Наступний крок —
введення нової операції над рядками, яка називається двійковим скалярним добутком.
Це операція над двійковими рядками однакової довжини.
Двійковий скалярний добуток двох рядків x і y
однакової довжини — це виключне АБО або парність
добутків окремих бітів.
Можна також сказати, що це XOR логічного І окремих бітів, оскільки І — це те саме, що добуток
для двійкових значень. Ще один спосіб описати
це — це 1 або 0
залежно від того,
чи є сума добутків окремих бітів непарною чи парною.
Це дуже схоже на скалярний добуток, якщо ми думаємо про рядки
як про вектори двійкових значень, але де ми обчислюємо за модулем 2,
або, іншими словами, беремо залишок від ділення на 2.
Це не справжній скалярний добуток, тому він заслуговує на іншу назву.
У нашому випадку ми можемо використовувати двійковий скалярний
добуток, щоб зробити нашу формулу для дії шару gate Hadamard
на стандартних базисних станах більш стислою, і ось вона.
Ми використовуємо той факт, що
оскільки ця сума тут знаходиться у
степені від'ємної 1,
все, що має значення, — чи є
вона парною чи непарною, але в іншому відношенні це в основному лише стисла
версія нашої формули.
До речі, двійковий
скалярний добуток симетричний у тому сенсі, що x dot
y і y dot x рівні,
тому ми вільні міняти
порядок, коли це корисно.
І тепер, маючи цю формулу, досить легко проаналізувати
circuit Дойча-Йожі.
Починаємо з n qubit у стані 0 і нижнього qubit у стані 1, і виконуємо gate Hadamard
на всіх них.
Отже, це стан
n + 1 qubit, який ми отримуємо.
Ми розглядаємо
нижній qubit окремо, тому що це буде зручно.
І знову ми побачимо феномен фазового
відбою.
WEBVTT
Ми можемо отримати цей вираз,
використовуючи нашу формулу, де підставляємо рядок із самих нулів для x і підставляємо x для y,
зауважуючи, що двійковий скалярний
добуток рядка із самих нулів із будь-яким рядком дорівнює 0.
Але ми також можемо просто міркувати про це безпосередньо. Ми беремо тензорний
добуток n станів плюс, і ось що ми отримуємо,
тензорований зі станом мінус. Потім застосовується gate UF, і тут відбувається феномен
фазового відбою.
Значення f від x XOR-ується на стан мінус для кожного x у сумі.
Тому f від x відбивається у фазу.
Тепер ми застосовуємо ще
один шар gate Hadamard лише до верхніх n qubit, і цього разу нам
справді потрібна формула.
І коли ми застосовуємо її та робимо лише трохи
спрощення, ми отримуємо цей стан тут.
Отже, це наш фінальний стан безпосередньо
перед вимірюваннями.
Стан виглядає трохи складно, і його важко спростити, тому що ми насправді нічого не знаємо
про функцію f.
Але пам'ятай, що все,
що нам насправді потрібно знати, — чи дають усі
вимірювання результат 0,
тому що саме це визначає нашу відповідь на задачу.
Якщо ми бачимо, що кожен
результат вимірювання дорівнює 0, ми робимо висновок, що функція константна.
І якщо будь-який один із
результатів вимірювань дорівнює 1, ми робимо висновок, що функція збалансована.
Тому обчислимо ймовірність отримати рядок із самих нулів
від вимірювань.
І виявляється, що це єдиний результат, який насправді легко обчислити, тому що двійковий скалярний
добуток рядка із самих нулів
з будь-яким рядком дорівнює нулю. Якщо ми розглянемо наш вектор і
подумаємо, що відбувається, коли y — рядок із самих нулів,
ми отримуємо цей вираз прямо тут
для ймовірності отримати рядок із самих нулів
від вимірювань.
І розглядаючи два можливі випадки, де f константна і f збалансована, ми бачимо, що ймовірність
отримати рядок із самих нулів дорівнює 1
у випадку, коли f константна, і нулю, коли f збалансована.
Коли f константна, сума дорівнює або 2 у степені
n, або від'ємному 2 у степені n, і ділення на 2 у степені n
та взяття абсолютного
значення у квадраті дає 1.
А коли f збалансована, сума дорівнює 0.
Це тому що ми отримаємо
позитивну 1 і від'ємну 1 однакову кількість разів,
тому вони всі скорочуються.
Ось і все. Алгоритм Дойча-Йожі
розв'язує задачу Дойча-Йожі за один запит,
і без помилок. За умови, що всі операції
виконані ідеально, він правильний кожного разу.
Отже, як це порівнюється з тим,
що ми можемо зробити класично?
Якщо ми наполягаємо на
детерміністичному алгоритмі, що отримує правильну відповідь
кожного разу, то в найгіршому випадку
нам потрібно 2 у степені n мінус 1 плюс 1 запитів, і це тому що ми маємо
запросити функцію
на більш ніж половині її вхідних даних, щоб бути впевненим у розв'язку.
Навіть якщо ми запитаємо функцію на 2 у степені n мінус 1
різних рядках вхідних даних, можливо, ми побачимо однакове вихідне значення
кожного разу, і це може бути тому,
що функція константна, або може бути, що вона насправді збалансована,
і нам просто неймовірно не пощастило побачити однакове вихідне
значення кожного разу.
Тому це є величезною перевагою
квантового над класичним — один запит проти
експоненціально великої кількості запитів.
Однак, якщо ми використовуємо
ймовірнісний алгоритм запитів і приймаємо невелику ймовірність неправильної відповіді,
тоді нам потрібно лише кілька запитів.
Зокрема, якщо ми
випадково вибираємо k рядків і обчислюємо функцію
на цих випадкових рядках,
то ми, мабуть, зможемо з'ясувати правильну відповідь.
Зокрема, ми відповідаємо 0 або "константна", коли отримуємо однакове значення функції кожного разу, і 1 або "збалансована",
коли бачимо два
різних значення функції.
Якщо ми це робимо, ми завжди будемо праві, коли
функція константна, тому що, звичайно, ми завжди бачимо однакове
вихідне значення в цьому випадку.
А якщо f збалансована, ми, швидше за все, побачимо
два різних вихідних значення.
Шанс того, що ми не побачимо
обидва вихідних значення в цьому випадку, такий самий, як шанс підкинути монету k разів
і отримати однаковий
результат кожного разу.
Тому, наприклад, якщо ми
встановимо k рівним 11, ймовірність отримати неправильну відповідь менше десятої частки відсотка.
Тому, особливо з урахуванням того факту, що квантові комп'ютери ніколи не будуть ідеальними в реальності, ми насправді не отримуємо такої
великої переваги тут,
але ми робимо прогрес, і у нас є вимірна перевага квантового над класичним, що виходить за рамки алгоритму Дойча.
Ми також можемо використовувати circuit Дойча-Йожі для розв'язання іншої задачі на запити, відомої як задача Бернштейна-Вазірані.
Ось формулювання цієї задачі. Вхідні дані — це функція
від n бітів до 1 біта, так само як і задача Дойча-Йожі,
WEBVTT
і знову ж таки, це задача з обіцянкою.
Цього разу обіцянка полягає в тому, що існує деякий рядок s з n бітів, для якого функція f
працює, як ти бачиш прямо тут,
де вивід задається
двійковим скалярним добутком вхідних даних із цим рядком s,
і мета — просто
знайти рядок s. Тому можна уявити, що
рядок s певним чином прихований,
але ми можемо дізнатися про нього,
роблячи запити до f, і наша мета — знайти
цей прихований рядок.
Щоб бути зрозумілим, більшість функцій
не задовольнять цю обіцянку, але, як завжди, нас цікавлять лише
вхідні функції, які задовольняють.
Виявляється, circuit Дойча-Йожі насправді розв'язує цю задачу
прямо з коробки.
Якщо ми запустимо його для
функції, як у нас тут, що задовольняє
обіцянку для деякого рядка s, вимірювання розкриють рядок s
без жодної постобробки.
Тож подивімося, як це працює.
Ми вже проаналізували
circuit Дойча-Йожі, тому ми можемо насправді просто
одразу перейти до кінця.
Ось вираз, який ми
мали раніше для стану безпосередньо перед вимірюваннями, і цей вираз був
дійсний для будь-якої функції f.
І тепер, якщо ми підставимо
те, що нам обіцяно щодо функції f, і спростимо,
ми отримуємо стан мінус
для нижнього qubit, тензорований із кет s для верхніх n qubit.
І тому ми отримуємо s при вимірюванні.
Є певна робота для виконання спрощень,
які я показав тут, і я не буду через це проходити в цьому відео,
але в підручниковому контенті для цієї серії є більше деталей, який ти можеш знайти, перейшовши за посиланням в описі відео,
або просто спробуй
самостійно для практики.
Отже, ми з'ясували, що
circuit Дойча-Йожі розв'язує задачу Бернштейна-Вазірані
за один запит.
Не надто важко показати,
що будь-який класичний алгоритм, чи то детерміністичний,
чи ймовірнісний, потребує щонайменше n запитів
для розв'язання задачі Бернштейна-Вазірані з простої причини, що нам потрібно n бітів
інформації для відновлення s,
і кожен запит дає нам щонайбільше 1 біт інформації.
Тому ми отримуємо ще одну перевагу квантового над класичним
алгоритмами запитів — один запит для квантових алгоритмів,
n запитів для класичних алгоритмів.
Варто витратити мить на те, щоб поговорити про
номенклатуру, що використовується в контексті цієї задачі, і трохи про її історію.
Люди іноді посилаються на алгоритм, який я щойно описав, як на алгоритм Бернштейна-Вазірані, але це насправді лише circuit
Дойча-Йожі,
і це те, що, власне,
дуже чітко зазначено в роботі Бернштейна і Вазірані.
Тому дещо дивно, що це називається алгоритмом Бернштейна-Вазірані, тому що це по суті те саме, що алгоритм Дойча-Йожі
без постобробки. Бернштейн і Вазірані, однак,
пішли на крок далі.
Вони визначили рекурсивну
версію цієї задачі, де потрібно
розв'язувати екземпляри задачі Бернштейна-Вазірані,
щоб розблокувати нові екземпляри задачі, упорядковані у
складну деревоподібну структуру.
Це надзвичайно штучна задача, але суть у тому, що
визначаючи задачу таким чином, вони могли ефективно розтягнути
розрив один проти n запитів між квантовим і класичним.
І що вони отримали — це
перший відомий приклад так званої надполіноміальної переваги квантового над ймовірнісними алгоритмами.
Ця рекурсивна версія задачі
Бернштейна-Вазірані також виявилася набагато пізніше
дуже цікавою в теорії обчислювальної складності з інших причин.
Так чи інакше, суть у тому, що
Бернштейн і Вазірані, безсумнівно, заслуговують визнання за свої важливі внески,
але насправді не має
сенсу називати це алгоритмом Бернштейна-Вазірані — це по суті лише
алгоритм Дойча-Йожі.
В останній частині уроку ми розглянемо ще
один квантовий алгоритм запитів, відомий як алгоритм Саймона.
Ти побачиш чітку схожість
між цим алгоритмом і алгоритмом Дойча-Йожі, але він відрізняється, і, що важливіше,
він розкриває набагато більшу перевагу квантового над класичним
алгоритмами запитів.
Зокрема, він дає нам
доведену експоненціальну перевагу квантового над класичними алгоритмами, навіть ймовірнісними.
Задача, яку він розв'язує, дещо штучна, і важко уявити ситуацію, в якій розв'язання цієї
задачі було б корисним,
але вона безпосередньо надихнула
Peter Shor на відкриття квантового алгоритму
для цілочисельної факторизації,
і це дуже переконливо підтримує
ідею моделі запитів як чашки Петрі, в якій можуть розвиватися квантові алгоритмічні
ідеї.
Почнімо із задачі на запити, яку розв'язує алгоритм Саймона, яка, як ти, мабуть, здогадався,
називається задачею Саймона.
Ось формулювання задачі, і нам потрібно буде його розпакувати, щоб зрозуміти, про що воно.
Перше, що
варто помітити: цього разу вхідна функція f відображає рядки з n
бітів у рядки з m бітів,
де m — деяке додатне ціле число, яке загалом не дорівнює одиниці.
WEBVTT
Це задача з обіцянкою. І, як і задача Бернштейна-Вазірані, обіцянка включає деякий рядок s, який можна розглядати як прихований рядок,
і також, як і
задача Бернштейна-Вазірані, мета — вивести
цей прихований рядок s.
Проте обіцянка цього разу
складніша, тому давайте розберемо її і
зрозуміємо, що вона каже.
Для початку просто прочитаємо її. Вона каже, що існує рядок s довжиною n
такий, що певна умова "якщо і тільки якщо" виконується для всіх варіантів рядків x і y з n бітів.
Зокрема, має
виконуватися умова, що f від x дорівнює f від y тоді і тільки тоді, коли виконується одна з
двох можливостей.
Перша можливість — x дорівнює y, а друга — що взявши побітове виключне АБО від x
і прихованого рядка s, ми отримуємо y.
Виявляється, це
досить сувора обіцянка в тому сенсі, що більшість
функцій її не задовольняють.
Лише дуже спеціальні функції
задовольняють цю умову.
Тепер, щоб краще зрозуміти цю обіцянку і, відповідно, саму задачу, ми розглянемо два основних випадки.
Перший випадок — s
є рядком із самих нулів.
У цьому випадку ми можемо спростити умову "якщо і тільки якщо" в обіцянці, тому що побітове
виключне АБО будь-якого рядка x
з рядком із самих нулів —
це просто рядок x.
Тому умова спрощується
до: f від x дорівнює f від y тоді і тільки тоді, коли x дорівнює y.
І це просто ще один спосіб сказати, що f є функцією "один до одного".
Іншими словами, рядок f від x має бути унікальним
для кожного можливого рядка x.
Отже, якщо f є функцією "один до одного", то обіцянка дійсно виконується, зокрема для s, що є
рядком із самих нулів,
і в цьому випадку це
правильний вивід.
Другий випадок — s
не є рядком із самих нулів, і що це означає: функція f має бути "два до одного".
Отже, для кожного вхідного рядка x є рівно ще один рядок, на який f відображає той самий
рядок, що й x,
і, крім того, цей інший рядок —
це рядок, який ми отримуємо, взявши побітове
виключне АБО від x із s.
Інший спосіб сказати це —
що кожен рядок x з n бітів має партнера, і цим партнером є рядок, який ми отримуємо
взявши побітове виключне АБО із s.
Будь-які два партнери мають давати
нам однаковий вихідний рядок, якщо ми підставляємо їх у f, і жодним іншим рядкам не дозволено давати нам
цей самий вихідний рядок.
Тому це обов'язково різні рядки, які виробляють партнери.
Ось приклад подібної функції, описаної таблицею значень.
Отже, це функція
від 3 бітів до 5 бітів.
Якщо ми уважно подивимося на цю таблицю
значень, ми виявимо, що обіцянка
виконується для рядка 011.
000 і 011 є партнерами. XOR будь-якого з них
із s дає нам інший,
і вони мають однакове вихідне значення, яке в цьому конкретному випадку — 10011, і жодні інші рядки не виробляють
цей самий вихідний рядок.
001 і 010 є партнерами, тому що XOR будь-якого
з них із s дає другий, і вони виробляють однакове вихідне значення,
яке знову ж таки не виробляється
жодним іншим рядком.
І ситуація
аналогічна для 100 і 111, а також для 101 і 110.
Тому, якщо вхідними даними задачі є ця функція, правильна відповідь — рядок 011.
Як я сказав раніше, більшість функцій не задовольняють цю обіцянку, це дуже специфічна умова.
Також варто зазначити, що
якщо обіцянка виконується, вона може виконуватися лише для одного рядка s.
Тому завжди є лише одна
правильна відповідь на цю задачу.
Ось і є задача Саймона. Як я сказав, важко уявити практичну ситуацію, в якій ти захочеш розв'язати цю задачу,
але це не головне. Головне — намагатися з'ясувати, в чому квантові комп'ютери гарні, і виявляється, що вони далеко перевершують
класичні алгоритми при
розв'язанні цієї конкретної задачі.
Тепер розглянемо
алгоритм Саймона, який розв'язує задачу Саймона.
Алгоритм полягає у
запуску квантового circuit, який ти бачиш тут, кілька разів, після чого виконується класичний
крок постобробки,
і ми будемо більш конкретними щодо того, що означає "кілька
разів" трохи пізніше.
Circuit дуже схожий
на circuit Дойча-Йожі, цього разу тому що функція
f відображає n бітів у m бітів,
gate запиту інший. Замість лише одного
qubit знизу, ми тепер маємо m qubit знизу
і n зверху, як і раніше.
Ключова відмінність полягає в тому, що ми
не встановлюємо стан мінус або кілька станів мінус знизу.
Ці нижні qubit всі
ініціалізовані у стан 0, і ці стани надходять прямо
до gate запиту.
WEBVTT
Тому в цьому алгоритмі не буде жодного фазового відбою — просто не так він працює.
Але, крім відмінностей,
про які я щойно згадав, він дуже схожий на
circuit Дойча-Йожі.
Ми застосовуємо шар gate Hadamard, потім застосовуємо gate запиту один раз, і потім застосовуємо ще один
шар gate Hadamard
після чого виконуємо вимірювання у стандартному базисі верхніх n qubit.
Ідея полягає в тому, що кожного разу, коли ми
запускаємо цей circuit і вимірюємо, ми отримуємо деякий рядок y, що говорить нам щось
про прихований рядок s
у задачі Саймона. І запускаючи circuit
кілька разів незалежно, ми зберемо достатньо
статистичних даних про s,
щоб бути в змозі з'ясувати, що
це таке, з великою впевненістю.
Тепер проаналізуємо квантовий
circuit для алгоритму Саймона, щоб побачити, що він робить.
Стан після першого
шару gate Hadamard виглядає ось так, схоже до того, що ми мали для
алгоритму Дойча-Йожі.
За винятком того, що цього разу нижні m qubit всі знаходяться у стані 0
замість станів мінус.
Після виконання gate запиту ми бачимо, що значення f від x записане на
нижні або найлівіші m qubit,
і це тому що f від x XOR-ований на рядок із самих нулів.
Тому знову ж таки в цьому алгоритмі не відбувається фазового відбою.
Потім ми виконуємо другий
шар gate Hadamard.
І використовуючи ту саму формулу, що й раніше, для дії
шару gate Hadamard на стандартний базисний
стан, кет x у цьому випадку,
як і в оригінальній формулі, ми отримуємо цей стан прямо тут, де дія gate Hadamard
стала більш очевидною. Але якщо ми хочемо, ми також можемо записати стан
у більш компактній формі, як ми маємо тут.
На цьому етапі ми вимірюємо верхні n qubit, щоб отримати деякий кінцевий рядок y з бітів, і нам просто потрібно з'ясувати,
якими є ймовірності
для різних рядків. І це допоможе нам зрозуміти,
яку інформацію ми отримуємо з цього рядка y про рядок s,
що прихований усередині функції f.
Нам знадобиться
трохи більше місця для цього, і діаграма circuit нам більше не потрібна, тому давайте позбудемося її та дамо собі
більше простору для аналізу.
Ось стан безпосередньо
перед вимірюваннями, які є вимірюваннями у стандартному базисі верхніх або найправіших n qubit.
Тому вимірювання
відповідає другому кет.
Позначимо через p від y ймовірність того, що вимірювання дають нам рядок y для кожного можливого y.
І якщо ми дотримуємося правил з Уроку 2, ми отримуємо, що кожна з цих ймовірностей є квадратом евклідової норми будь-якого вектора, тензорованого
зі стандартним базисним станом,
що відповідає чому в
нашому векторі квантового стану.
Це дає нам цей вираз прямо тут.
Тепер, щоб краще розібратися
з цими ймовірностями, нам потрібно використати деяку нотацію, і ти, можливо, вже знайомий з цією нотацією,
бо вона досить поширена в математиці.
По-перше, коли ми говоримо про
область значень функції f, ми просто маємо на увазі множину всіх рядків, які можуть виходити з цієї функції.
Тобто це множина всіх f від x для всіх можливих
варіантів рядка вхідних даних x.
По-друге, ми будемо використовувати цю нотацію, яку ти бачиш прямо тут, для позначення множини всіх рядків вхідних даних x,
що f відображає у даний рядок z, для будь-якого вибору
z, який ми хочемо розглянути.
Це трохи схоже на
обернену функцію f, але це не справжня обернена, тому що f не обов'язково оборотна.
Ми також бачимо, що маємо
множину як аргумент у лівій частині, і в цьому випадку це множина, що містить
лише один рядок z,
і це ключ до розуміння того, що ми не говоримо про
оберену функцію f — це називається прообразом.
Прообраз може бути
визначений більш загально для будь-якої множини, що подається як аргумент, не лише для множини, що містить
один елемент,
але це все, що нам знадобиться. Це не найкраща
нотація у світі, тому що її легко
сплутати з оберненою,
але вона достатньо зрозуміла
і широко використовується, тому ми будемо її використовувати.
І тепер, якщо ми використовуємо цю нотацію, ми можемо переписати вектор, квадрат евклідової норми якого ми беремо, щоб отримати ймовірність
вимірювання кожного рядка y.
Ми робимо це тому, що нам потрібно побачити,
якими є коефіцієнти для кожного окремого стандартного базисного стану, і це не очевидно з
цього виразу тут,
тому що, загалом, ми можемо
мати кілька варіантів x, що дають нам однаковий рядок f від x.
По суті, все, що ми робимо, —
це розбиваємо суму по x, спочатку підсумовуючи за всіма
z в області значень f,
а потім усередині цієї суми, підсумовуючи за всіма x у прообразі z, або, точніше,
прообразі множини,
що містить рядок z.
Це дозволяє нам замінити f від x на z всередині кет тут.
І сума за всіма різними рядками
x, що f відображає до кожного z, зібрана в
коефіцієнт для кожного кет.
Ми по суті розкладаємо рядки по кошиках, підсумовуємо по кошиках, а потім підсумовуємо по
рядках у кожному кошику,
WEBVTT
але це еквівалентно просто
підсумовуванню за всіма рядками.
Тому ми отримуємо вираз, еквівалентний
тому, з якого ми починали,
і тепер ми можемо обчислити
квадрат евклідової норми.
Це просто сума квадратів абсолютних значень
коефіцієнтів, тому ми отримуємо цей вираз прямо тут
для наших ймовірностей.
Звичайно, дай собі
час перевірити це, якщо ти вирішиш це зробити, потрібен час, щоб звикнути до всього цього
і бути здатним виконувати
ці обчислення, і що більше практики ти собі даєш, тим легше це стає.
Поки що ми насправді
не використовували обіцянку в задачі Саймона взагалі.
Наш аналіз цих ймовірностей насправді працює для будь-якої функції f, але тепер час думати конкретно про задачу Саймона.
Ми розіб'ємо все на ті ж два випадки,
що й раніше.
Перший випадок — s
є рядком із самих нулів, а другий — s
не є рядком із самих нулів.
У першому випадку, коли s є рядком із самих нулів, все досить просто.
У цьому випадку, як ми бачили раніше, f є функцією "один до одного", тому є один рядок x,
що відображається в кожний рядок
z з області значень f.
Це робить квадрат абсолютного значення суми за цими рядками рівним 1, тому що є лише
один доданок у сумі,
це або плюс 1, або від'ємна 1, але це не має значення, тому що ми беремо
квадрат абсолютного значення, і тому отримуємо одиницю.
В області значень f є 2 у степені n
елементів, і ми знаємо це тому, що f "один до одного", тому є один рядок в
області для кожного рядка вхідних даних.
І якщо ми обчислимо весь вираз, виявимо, що кожен рядок y з'являється з ймовірністю
один поділити на 2 у степені n.
Тобто, іншими словами,
вимірювання дають нам рядок y, вибраний рівномірно випадково.
Це може здатися не дуже корисним, але ми насправді зможемо
відрізнити цю поведінку від поведінки у випадку,
коли s не є рядком із самих нулів, і ми незабаром побачимо, як це відбувається.
Але наразі ми просто зауважуємо, що якщо
f задовольняє обіцянку в задачі Саймона у випадку, коли s є рядком із самих нулів,
тоді результат вимірювань — рівномірно випадковий рядок.
Тепер перейдемо до другого випадку, коли обіцянка
виконується для рядка s, що не є рядком із самих нулів.
У цьому випадку, як ми обговорювали раніше, кожен рядок z в області значень f має рівно два рядки, що відображаються в нього,
тому що кожен рядок має партнера, і кожна пара партнерів
відображається у деякий унікальний рядок, і зокрема, партнер кожного рядка
— це рядок, який ми отримуємо XOR-ячи із s.
Тому, якщо ми вибираємо будь-який рядок
z з області значень f і даємо назву w будь-якому з
рядків, що f відображає в z,
то XOR від w із s —
це інший рядок, що відображається в z.
Дивлячись лише на один доданок у нашій сумі, що відповідає будь-якому рядку z з області, який ми маємо на увазі,
ми бачимо, що можемо
записати його більш явно, як ми маємо прямо тут.
У нас два рядки в прообразі z: w і w XOR із s.
Тому ми можемо записати суму,
як ти бачиш на екрані, і тепер ми можемо винести множник
від'ємна 1 у степені w.y.
Цей множник буде
або плюс 1, або від'ємна 1, тому він зникає, коли ми
беремо абсолютне значення,
і те, що залишається, — це
цей вираз прямо тут.
Деталі тут не всі показані, і не очевидно, що це працює саме так, але ти можеш перевірити, що ці
два вирази рівні,
повернувшись до визначення
двійкового скалярного добутку і подумавши про те, що відбувається, коли ці речі знаходяться у
степені від'ємної 1,
подібно до того, що ми мали для
задачі Бернштейна-Вазірані.
Нарешті, ми можемо розбити цей
вираз на два випадки.
Він дорівнює 4, коли двійковий скалярний
добуток s і y дорівнює 0, і дорівнює 0, коли двійковий
скалярний добуток s і y дорівнює 1.
Зауваж зокрема, що
тут взагалі немає залежності від w або z — залежить лише від s і y.
Причина цього —
дуже специфічна і особлива природа обіцянки.
По суті, саме тому обіцянку було сформульовано таким чином, щоб все вийшло ось так.
Знову ж таки, кожен рядок має партнера, якого ми отримуємо XOR-ячи з
цим одним прихованим рядком s,
і саме це все і забезпечує.
Тепер ми можемо повернутися до
виразу для ймовірностей і підставити значення.
Коли s не є рядком із самих нулів, в області значень f є 2 у степені n мінус 1
елементів,
що є половиною від
кількості рядків вхідних даних, і підставляння щойно обчислених значень дає цю формулу прямо тут.
Тому цього разу y не є
повністю випадковим рядком, а скоріше y рівномірний рівно над половиною рядків з n бітів,
WEBVTT
і зокрема, він
рівномірний над тими рядками, що мають двійковий скалярний
добуток, рівний 0, із s.
Тепер, коли ми знаємо, як працює circuit
для алгоритму Саймона, і зокрема які
ймовірності для різних результатів вимірювання,
залишається пояснити, як це допомагає нам розв'язати задачу Саймона.
Підсумовуючи те, що ми щойно дізналися: якщо функція f задовольняє обіцянку в задачі Саймона,
коли прихований рядок s
є рядком із самих нулів, ми отримуємо повністю випадковий
рядок від вимірювань,
де кожен рядок y з n бітів
рівно ймовірний.
Якщо ж, з іншого боку, функція f задовольняє обіцянку для іншого рядка s, що не дорівнює
рядку із самих нулів,
то ми отримуємо випадковий рядок y, що має двійковий скалярний добуток
рівний 0 із s, і серед усіх цих рядків
кожен y рівно ймовірний.
Але ми ніколи не отримаємо рядок y, що має двійковий скалярний добуток
рівний 1 із s.
Питання стає: "Чи достатньо цієї інформації
для визначення s?" І відповідь, як я вже
запропонував, — так,
за умови, що ми запускаємо
circuit достатню кількість разів.
Зокрема, припустимо,
що ми запускаємо circuit k разів, де K дорівнює n плюс r,
де r — деяке число, яке буде контролювати
ймовірність успішного відновлення s.
Просто як приклад, якщо
ми виберемо r рівним 10, ми будемо успішні з
ймовірністю більшою за 99,9%,
тому r не потрібно бути надто великим.
Загалом, ймовірність невдачі менша за ймовірність
підкинути справедливу монету r разів і щоразу отримати орла.
Тому якщо 99,9% недостатньо,
возьми r рівним 20, і шанс невдачі —
менше одного з мільйона,
або вибери будь-яке r,
яке тебе влаштовує. Не можна гарантувати правильний розв'язок, але можна зробити
ймовірність помилки нехтуємо малою
для всіх практичних цілей.
Тут ми називаємо ці
рядки y1 через yk, де ми використовуємо верхні індекси, щоб допомогти нам назвати ці рядки,
просто щоб ми могли залишити нижні індекси для позначення окремих
бітів цих рядків.
Тому це не показники ступеня
або щось подібне — це просто назви, які ми даємо цим k рядкам.
Кожен із них має довжину n, тому що ми отримали їх,
запустивши circuit для алгоритму Саймона.
Тому ми можемо записати
окремі біти цих k рядків, як ти бачиш прямо тут.
Що ми тепер робимо — це створюємо матрицю m, де кожен елемент цієї матриці — біт, і ми отримуємо ці біти з рядків,
що ми щойно виміряли, так само, як показано тут.
Отже, ця матриця має k рядків і n стовпців, і всі її елементи — двійкові значення.
Тепер, ми не знаємо, що таке s. Це те, що ми намагаємося знайти, але просто уявімо на мить, що ми знали б s,
і утворили б вектор-стовпець
із бітів s, так само, як показано прямо тут.
Якщо ми помножимо цей вектор на m, а потім візьмемо результат за модулем 2, або інший спосіб сказати це —
замінити додавання
виключним АБО, тоді ми обов'язково
отримаємо нульовий вектор.
Це тому що кожен з
елементів цього результуючого вектора — не що інше, як двійковий скалярний добуток s
з одним із рядків матриці m.
Якщо s є рядком із самих нулів, ми завжди отримаємо нульовий вектор від двійкового скалярного добутку.
А якщо s не є рядком із самих нулів, ми отримаємо це з того, що ми
знаємо про ймовірності для рядків y1 через yk.
Зокрема, двійковий скалярний добуток із s завжди дорівнює нулю для всіх цих рядків.
Простий спосіб сказати це — вектор,
утворений з бітів s, завжди знаходиться в нуль-просторі матриці m,
за умови, що ми виконуємо всю арифметику за модулем 2, але, звичайно, ми не знаємо, що таке s,
ми намагаємося знайти s.
Але що ми можемо зробити — обчислити
нуль-простір цієї матриці m, знову ж таки, за модулем 2.
Зокрема, ми можемо зробити це за допомогою техніки
Гаусового виключення, що є процедурою, яку часто викладають
у вступних курсах з лінійної алгебри.
Вона відмінно працює, коли ми виконуємо всю арифметику за модулем 2, і це може бути виконано досить
ефективно за допомогою комп'ютера.
І якщо ми обчислимо нуль-простір матриці m, з урахуванням конкретного способу, яким ці k рядків
були обрані випадково,
ми зможемо відновити s з ймовірністю більшою за
1 мінус 2 у степені від'ємного r.
Щоб бути конкретним, те, що ми побачимо з ймовірністю більшою за
1 мінус 2 у степені від'ємного r, — це те, що нуль-простір
містить нульовий вектор,
як він завжди є для кожної матриці, а також вектор, що відповідає s, чи то нульовий вектор, чи ні.
І найважливіше, ніякі інші вектори не з'являться в нуль-просторі.
Насправді це не надто важко довести, хоча я не буду вдаватися в деталі.
WEBVTT
Ідея полягає в тому, що якщо ми маємо якийсь інший рядок, що не є нульовим
вектором і не є s, то кожен один із випадкових
рядків, y1 через yk,
по суті виб'є
його з нуль-простору з ймовірністю половина.
Тому після k спроб він
навряд чи збережеться, і насправді, жоден із
рядків, що не мають там бути,
навряд чи збережеться. І дуже простий факт
із теорії ймовірностей, відомий як нерівність об'єднання, може бути
використаний для встановлення цього.
Я не пояснив усіх
деталей тут, але сподіваюся, ти розумієш ідею, що обчислюючи нуль-простір за модулем 2 цієї матриці m,
ми, швидше за все, відновимо s, і саме так алгоритм Саймона
розв'язує задачу Саймона.
Залишається сказати лише одне
про задачу Саймона, і це стосується класичної
складності цієї задачі,
тобто скільки запитів потрібен класичний алгоритм запитів для розв'язання задачі Саймона.
Відповідь — багато, загалом.
Різні точні
твердження можна зробити про класичну
складність цієї задачі, і ось лише одне з них.
Якщо ми маємо будь-який ймовірнісний
алгоритм запитів і цей алгоритм робить менше ніж 2 у степені n поділити на 2
мінус 1, мінус 1 запитів,
тобто це кількість запитів,
що є експоненціальною від n, тоді цей алгоритм не зможе розв'язати задачу Саймона,
з ймовірністю щонайменше половина.
Іноді доведення
результатів неможливості на кшталт цього може бути дуже складним, але цей не надто важко довести
за допомогою елементарного
ймовірнісного аналізу.
Я не буду робити це у цьому відеоуроці і натомість зосереджуся
на інтуїції за цим.
Ми намагаємося знайти прихований рядок s, але поки ми не запитуємо функцію на двох рядках, що мають
однакове вихідне значення,
ми отримуємо дуже обмежену
інформацію про s.
По суті, все, що ми дізнаємося, — це
те, що прихований рядок s не є виключним АБО будь-яких двох різних
рядків, які ми запитали,
і якщо ми запитаємо функцію менше ніж цю кількість запитів, все ще залишиться багато варіантів s,
що не були виключені.
Це не формальний доказ,
але це основна ідея.
Отже, підсумовуючи, алгоритм Саймона надає нам разючу перевагу квантового над класичними
алгоритмами в рамках моделі запитів.
Зокрема, алгоритм Саймона
розв'язує задачу Саймона з кількістю запитів, що є лінійною від кількості вхідних
бітів n нашої функції,
тоді як будь-який класичний алгоритм,
навіть ймовірнісний, повинен робити кількість
запитів, що є експоненціальною від n,
щоб розв'язати задачу Саймона з розумною ймовірністю успіху.
Правда, задача Саймона є дещо штучною задачею, яку, мабуть, ніхто
насправді не хоче розв'язати,
але це другорядне. Іноді ідеї потрібно розробити, перш ніж їх застосовують на практиці.
І дійсно, Peter Shor чітко зазначив, що саме алгоритм Саймона надихнув його нині
відомий квантовий алгоритм
для цілочисельної факторизації, який ми побачимо через кілька уроків.
І це кінець Уроку 5.
У цьому уроці ми розглянули модель запитів обчислень і побачили прогресію прикладів
квантових алгоритмів,
що демонструють переваги над класичними алгоритмами
в рамках цієї моделі.
Насправді є набагато більше
відомого про модель запитів і квантові алгоритми для інших задач, про які
я не говорив.
Тому, якщо ти знаходиш цю
модель цікавою, є ще чимало
чого дізнатися про неї.
Наш наступний крок — відійти
від моделі запитів і рухатися до моделі обчислень,
що є більш репрезентативною
для типів задач, які ми сподіваємося розв'язати на практиці.
Сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене на Уроці 6, де ми зосередимося головним чином на
закладанні основи для вивчення квантових алгоритмів.
А звідти ми перейдемо до деяких
конкретних квантових алгоритмів, включаючи алгоритм Шора
для цілочисельної факторизації
у наступних уроках. До зустрічі!